you
[Music]
it I'm thrilled to welcome Leon to MSR
for the keynote he needs no introduction
I just call out a few highlights I I was
very happy when the Turing Award winners
this year actually credited Leon's
foundational work on neural networks in
the early 90s also his work on
large-scale learning to do stochastic
gradient he's always had profound
insights on going from learning to
reasoning and going from interpolation
to extrapolation but today he tells me
that title of his keynote is going to be
convexity he's just gonna tell us about
convexity so without any further ado
take the video well thank you very much
for inviting me and I would like to
apologize because I saw this morning lot
a very polished talk and I just finished
mine so so I hope there might be chance
that something inside is stupid and
fully you're going to tell me and the
the motivation for this talki because
the title was geometry of AI so I
thought it had to do with geometry and a
couple years ago I think that was
written in two thousand sixteen and
seventeen the marks dot on it works okay
so I have to yell we wrote a paper
that's published in something that a bit
obscure but it shouldn't be obscure
because brotherman is the Eisenmann
brotherman of the kernel and that was
for the forty years anniversary of his
passing out and there was a lot of
groundwork about trying to understand
the topology of guns and what's
happening and at the end we had a
strange theorem that was very very
simple and somehow we were smart enough
to give it a catchy name convexity
Ellicott but I didn't think too much of
it because it's so simple and also
because the results that we we get with
this theorem I don't find it so good you
know I just I don't happy I'm not happy
with the bound it's to to lose
but in the recent years we have plenty
of papers with the neural tangent
kernels and papers about the
optimization in neural networks and
every time I go back to this ID because
I think it makes things very simple at
least it speaks to my intuition so I
would like to share that with you and
see whether this is a useful tool I one
claim to say something extremely new but
it's an interesting way to look at it so
some are easy and I'm going to speak
about the convex optimization a la carte
and then discuss what it is about
approximation property global
minimization and the parameter ization
bias and then in the third part because
then I realize that you gave me a
one-hour slot
I'm going to try to talk about what was
in the paper at the beginning because it
also gives another example where the
geometry is very different and you can
still use that result so I'm supposed to
start very slowly because at the
beginning it's so simple that we can
pretty much prove everything except one
thing but that's not too important so
background so I'm working in a polish
metric space let's just think a metric
space that's sort of nice and the curve
is just a mapping from let's say 0 1 2
my my space that continues and connects
two points and I call it gamma sub
treaty because it I want it to be
compact so there is a lot of things
about curves in metric spaces there is a
whole field of neutral geometry and I'm
going to shortcut much of most of it the
only thing I really need to do is that I
need the bounded speed curve which in
fact pretty much means Lipschitz there
is a lot of background about that
because you can speak about constant
speed curves and then you go to constant
speed geodesics and all this business
but basically I say that if I make a
small movement in the parameter T of my
curve sorry I'm just going to do that
the distance between the two points is
not too large
and I'm going to make some definitions
of wit convexity I'm suppose and given a
family of curves see I know what they
are I don't say anything about them and
I say that the subset of my space is
convex respect to this family of curve
one for every pair X Y there is a curve
that connects X to Y and is completely
connected in F so basically I can stay
in my set and go from X to Y with one of
my curves and I say that the real
function is convector to see one for
every curve the restriction of F to the
curve is convex
that is for every T a B basically you
have the convex normal convexity thing
so the first point is that if my family
of curves are line segments in the
Euclidean space this is normal convexity
the second one there is an asymmetry
I still subset this convex when there is
one curve and we our function is convex
on every curve so if you have several
curves connecting two points the second
definition is more demanding so I can we
can iterate a bit because the only thing
I'm going to use is that it's convex
between the endpoints so basically that
if I draw that for any T F of gamma T is
less than the mixture of f of gamma 0
and F of gamma 1 so it could be a little
bit like this below I'm not going to
care and the result is very simple is
that if F is convex respect to a family
of curve if a cost function is endpoints
conductor effective from your curve then
basically all the level sets are
connected and if C only contains bounded
speed curves or local minima are global
so basically it's an essential property
of convexity that's preserved in the
setup where I have a curve I want
make sense the proof of this is very
simple if I type X&Y that belongs to my
level set
so basically f of X is less than M F F
of Y to the N this since F is convex
respect to my family of curve there is a
curve inside that connected and stays in
F since F is endpoint convex I can say
that F of gamma t is less than 1 minus T
of FX plus TF of Wilde's is both F of T
and F of Y is more than M this is more
than M means that gamma T belongs to my
level set therefore the level set is
path connected the Falls connected now
the second part about the local minima I
say that a point is a local minimum if
there is a ball such that every point in
the ball is greater or equal than the
center of the ball reasoning by
contradiction as soon there is a y so
that f of y is less than f of X so I
just take a curve that connects X to Y
it supposed to be bounded speed and
because it's bounded speed I have this
property which is the Lipchitz property
of the bounded speed and therefore if I
take epsilon over 2 K F of gamma epsilon
over 2 K is greater than F of gamma 0
which is f of X but with endpoint on
exit II have the opposite inequality
with the strict inequality therefore not
possible therefore my as my
contradiction and my local minimum
cannot be above the value in some other
points F so so far very simple let's
take a simple machine learning example X
to be continuous function from some
input space to some other space a subset
in X such that F is the family of
function that's family tried by some
theta I didn't word parametric because I
want to sort of kernel things let's L
the laws be convex in his first argument
which is the output of model training
examples and define the empirical
function where f so in the loss I love
to FM sorry my empirical cost function
is f X
F in my any function basically and
computes the empirical rows and I'm
going to take curves that represent just
mixtures they're just thread line
segments in the function space which
means that what I'm going to say now is
something that could be obtained by
plane convexity arguments I'm going to
relax that letter so the cost function f
is trivially convex respected my curves
because essentially I'm drawing curves
in the output spaces of my network for
examples and because the loss is convex
this is convex no problem so if my
family of function is convex respect to
my curves the theorem applies and that's
true for linear models that proof or
kernel models and for neural networks
well almost why almost because if a very
richly parameterized I shouldn't say
over parameterize is of the right world
here richly parameterize neural network
as good approximation property but I can
approximate my my linear mixture so I
can pass close to the straight line but
this is not sufficient to prove anything
because a implies B the solution I mean
that almost a implies almost be that be
too nice and this is where the curves
can be useful so what does it mean that
my network can approximate well well I'm
going to simplify I'm going to say that
there is a Afghan theta T so a family a
function in my family that close to the
mixture gamma T with the distance that's
basic politics so basically define now
around the line that goes from F to G my
two functions in the function space I
define a kind of cigar and as inside a
cigar
I have functions in my family that do
that now proving this kind that this
kind of seiga exist this is cumbersome
you can do it it's just you can play
play pages doing that stuff that's
interesting what's interesting is that
this error coefficient here gets smaller
the network get bigger and approximates
better so I'm just going to stay at that
so now my set of curves are going to be
all the curves that are contained in
such cigar shaped regions so I'm gonna
have two points I draw the cigar and
every curve that stays inside this is
one of my curves I'm happy and by
construction now f is convex respect to
the set of curve because for every two
function there is a curve inside the
cigar that I assume belongs to F so the
question is is the cost function and
point convex respect to this family and
well what's happening is that if you
bound the domain to some fixed domain
which you can do by claiming that the
innovator the the level set approver for
very high hem are connected by other
arguments like the other ways to do that
you can say that the losses you can make
some Lipschitz assumption with ross and
basically you have the same kind of
thing that's happening to the function
your f of theta T is less than F of the
mixture plus some quadratic term lambda
T 1 minus T lambda is the product
receive relief is constant and the error
that I had and applying this I get this
and this is not like strong convexity
because the sine is wrong in fact if the
loss was new strongly convex instead of
doing this I could add a new T 1 minus T
and if lambda is smaller than mu I'm
done but you stop the case I have to
deal with function that are not convex
but almost convex they they they can be
little bit above and this is where there
is the second part of the theorem which
I call the or mock convex optimization
so same thing f convex respective
familiar curve and for each curve the
cost function that is 5 something like
this with design work anymore
in red the convex valuation done and
when we can say now which is also
something that's very simple to prove
is that if M is greater than the minimum
of the function on f plus lambda the
lambda that appears in then the levels
that are connected and basically if you
also have the bound that speed the
constraint it means that any local
minimum is at most gamma above the
global minimum so why is it so it's
again super simple so take two points x
and y in my level set and what their
values less than m and I pick a Zed in
the level set so the F of Z is less than
M minus gamma so what you can set that's
below and now I'm going to make two
curves where it connects X to Z another
one z 2y actually the same construction
and if I have these two curves then I
have my path and it's part connected so
I think it's easier to see it on this
graph if gamma 0 is X and gamma 1 is
that M is my level set and my well I'm
not going to be below that line I'm
going to be below that red curve here
and if Z is officially below X I can
ensure the red curve is all below M so
that curve between X and Z it's entirely
in the level set
similarly occur from z2 wise and tally
the level set and there forever my
conclusion that I've found the path
connecting any x and y in my level set
so see it's very short yes you can just
take this cigar and take your function
class to be defined as all the madness
my class of curves are all the curves in
the sugar in the Scylla but each color
corresponds to an FTD really how do i
then map it back to each occur
correspond no so I have several objects
have the family of curve which is the
one which is going to allow me to
customize the notion of convexity the
way I want and my family of curves
instead of being just line segments
between two functions are going to be
between any two functions any curve
that's continuous and stays in the cigar
to say that my familiar function the one
that's the model is convex I need to say
that one of these curves stays inside
the family and because the my
assumptions the model has good
approximation property good enough that
the cigar contents approximations I can
make a curve in there you have to be
careful about continuous data a little
bit and the second part is I say that
the cost function is convex when it's
restriction to all the curves is convex
so in particular has to become less
respect to the curve that's in my family
and I can relax this notion of convexity
actually I can use endpoint convex and
like now say almost convex where assume
that the convexity is defective by a
coefficient lambda T 1 minus T and 1 is
defective in that way the thing you can
prove is that the level sets are
connected until you grow gamma a both
the optimum so in lambda above the
optimal weight lambda yes I wrote lambda
so which means that if you have a decent
algorithm you're going to shrink the
level set whenever you decent you're
going to go there now if you remember
well I said that the bigger the network
the better it approximate and the
smaller mass singer
that means upon network becomes bigger
this lambda can be smaller and smaller
and so I go to the global minimum so um
yes yes yes yeah the gamma should be
lambda because I just changed it in the
last minute because I had too many
gammas in my talk so this gamma is is
this gamma here it's supposed to be
lambda but this gamma t is still a gamma
you see so so I had a terminology
problem at the slightest not so good but
the real idea is here so basically
whenever pointed us level m and one that
lambda below M even if I have a slight
convexity defect I can remain below M
connecting them
one such point is enough so if you think
where we are now this says in a
relatively simple way that if you have a
neural network that are strong
approximation properties with reasonable
assumptions a decent deliver set are
going to be connected up to almost as
low as you want because you can get the
sia as small as you want and a decent
are going is we could work quite nicely
and the local minima or at the bottom
which is sort of cool meaning that there
are recent results that say things like
that but they are a lot more complicated
so what can be understood from this so
if I were to discuss this I'd say that
these results are independent of the
parameter ization of my family of
function this doesn't matter the only
thing that really matters is whether any
two point in the familiar function can
be close enough or a follower can be
either connected by a suitable curve or
the suitable curve can be well
approximated by elements of my family
which is sort of nice in the data space
the level set can be very non convex
they can be very bizarre but they're
connected when you have the central go
in is built order but because the
learning algorithm operates in the theta
space it means that whatever implicit
biases are in the learning algorithm are
basically based on how you paralyze the
things and the things like which global
minimum is returned in another
parameterize model or which solution is
written when you do early stopping that
really depends on the dynamic of the
learning algorithm which itself depends
on the family tradition so somehow the
fact that you can go to a global minimum
and a global minimum and increased bias
are they quite disconnected
one you use mixture curves which is what
I did so far which is curve data either
straight line or very close to a
straight line basically when the
familiar function are strong enough
approximation properties to closely
represent linear mixture of any two of
its function
any reasonable learning algorithm I mean
the decent stuff will event we feel find
a near global minimum if the network is
good enough
there are many recent results and I
Peter gave the list so so there in the
line of the knurled there are tangent
kernels and all these recent we solve a
sort of nice
they just typically more complex in this
series of paper there is one that I
found quite interesting is the one from
transition all I on about lazy learning
where it makes a claim that you know you
have the normal tangent kind of approach
and what it calls the Lizzie learning
regime that goes through a solution but
this solution often doesn't generalize
that well and this we can see it because
we have the decoupling between the
parameterization and the convexity
property of the convexity like a
properties that allowed me to say that
I'm going down so basically the the
result means that the learning are going
as the possibility to overcome the
parameterization and follow the
complicated level set and reach a
solution but doesn't mean it's a good
idea in particular if you have a lot of
solutions the the solution space is
large which is common in over
parameterize network it might also have
a very strange shape which is connected
with strange and the learning algorithm
that with a certain parameter ization
might reach a better minimum than the
minimum that you would consider if you
just got just something that does a
descent without any other constraint now
this is doomed to be prone specific know
whether the parameterization is really
relevant to a problem
and therefore allows us to have an
implicit bias that's going to give a
good solution instead of the solution by
default which is still achievable which
is good to know but it's yeah it has to
be program specific or maybe you can use
different curves what about using other
kinds of curves yes can we go back to
natural radians and think about them as
implying natural gradient is different
there's natural gradient you consider
the parameterize space that's a romanian
space so you don't look outside here I'm
defining a geometry in the whole space
of function and then defining the subset
of models and I want my subset of
mothers who have complexity properties
and my cost functions are convexity
properties respect to some curves so so
somehow looking outside of the
parametric model allows me to say that
what matters to me is not the
palletization but really the geometry of
the familiar function one view to the
right set of yours so so yes in two
minutes I mean if you late the geometry
the journey there were many many thought
would you define natural gradient to the
geometry of the curves in your curve set
because that tells you how
yes math in that case you have the
second the first property the convexity
of the family a function is achieved by
default because you're just looking
inside and the second one gives you
problems so the trick here is that we
can balance the two you know when I had
the problem that because my my family of
functions were not convex because they
were just approximately they could just
approximate the line I was able to say
okay I'm going to take more curves and
then the play with the other part so
allows me to shift the difficulty from
one hand to the other hand or after the
theorem model the convexity of the
function versus the convexity of the
family so it
I didn't know when I wrote it but it
turns out that is quite a powerful tool
even though it's super simple but is my
what I think now maybe I'm wrong you
know just I thought that a lot of people
might tell me if I'm wrong here
so that give me a chance to discuss what
was actually in the paper because so in
the paper this was at the very end of
the paper to give a result that I never
liked very much and I'm going to speak
about these shortcomings but there's
some interesting aspects there so it's
about implicit models like Ganz V AES
and Douglas and it's also a nice example
because an example where I'm going to
use very different kind of curves
mixtures in fact I'm going to show that
mixture really don't work so the reason
why I'm interested in implicit models is
because I would like to find the
important properties of the world rather
than the one that are specific to the
particular distribution I want to find
important properties that are invariant
across distributional changes of a
certain kind that's another talk but
basically instead of having a sorry
instead of having a model that's
engineered to resent through the
distribution so here is very close who
inside the model and I can use any
distance I want to use very simple
models that we're very important
properties but I don't care that the
data distribution is realistic so the
distance between the true distribution
and the one in them model the what the
thing I'm going to minimize really
matters and if you want to do this
maximum likelihood is not the good tool
because what is a simple model it's
something that involves the copper
observed or latent variables the
distribution is degenerate supported by
a low dimensional manifold that means
doesn't have a density so there is no
density estimation so the workaround
that one uses is to augment the simple
model with the noise model and then you
tweak the world model until you get the
results you want
and you call it and supervised learning
and it's not really it but I would like
to know whether it's possible not to
have to add a noise model but just find
interesting distances that have the
right properties and I should say I
haven't found that yet but in the way
they are coupled things so implicit
modeling is that an observed data
through the distribution Q and I have a
known distribution that I pushed forward
through pairwise functions in order to
create the parametric distribution and I
can get samples so basically I have two
samplers one that's data limited another
one that's unlimited and I want to
compare this distribution in order to
optimize theta so the good thing is that
this can have a low dimensional support
basically this is very good to represent
distributions with a low money for
support you can write that in
mathematics what's interesting is this
ash notation that's common in
transportation literature where I see
that G theta R mu means the push forward
of the distribution new through the
function G theta I'm going to use that a
lot so and that's good for the generic
distributions so now compare
distributions so before being too smart
we can look what's in the literature
because there's a big literature about
comparing distributions and you have
what our thing that basically generated
the strong topology like total variation
will back lie bruh which requires
densities it's not a distance because
densities a symmetry possibly infinite
Jensen Shannon which was what was you
tease used in the first version of the
guns and that nobody used it because it
really doesn't work that symmetric the
general cry density is bounded and is
square root actually a proper distance
and then you have the more recent thing
so there is the Vassar Stein 1 so the
vast certain distance are as assume
everybody knows or should I explain the
way I can explain because I have time so
are my two distribution P in Q so that's
the graph I took from the pair de
Gabrielle para introduction to this
region P and Q and I want to find the
John distribution with marginal P and Q
in the John distribution test
me where I should transport grains of
probability from what one food from one
distribution to create the second one
and so pi is this so it's the minimum of
a distribution or John distribution that
have marginal P and Q of some cost
function that tells me whether the
transport is expensive or not and by the
duality theorem is the supremum of all
Lipschitz one function of the
expectation over the first distribution
of f of X minus the expectation of the
second distribution of f of Y that's
always defined it involves the metric of
the underlined underlying space either
in the density there of you had the
Lipschitz one nature of the function and
that was the inspiration for the vast
angle which is almost visage vanish but
got some successes so another one that
surprised me when I threw the first of
it because I'm an ignorant you know in
the paper by Genbu Shakur and that's the
energy distance of secondly and it's a
bit of thing while you take the
expectation distance between two points
of distribution and you tell to and you
remove the inside the distribution
differences and you can show and I'm
going to do that here that this is the
same with basically the distance that
I'm using here all the kernels I'm using
in the MMD method the object weight on
MMG plays the same role essentially and
again you have this both vast surf time
and energy distance M&D define the weak
topology we need a depend really on the
mid the distribution of the metric space
below they also approximate this
supremum with neural network so they
know they do spot with the canal I think
by thou art with retinas new methods
that called MMD gun will do something
smart with the cannon but also as an
adversarial term so in fact the escapes
the this definition so in the domed
ecology of the same geometry
so now I'm going to look at mixtures in
distribution space now for every TPT p0
p1 r2 distribution PT is the mixture of
the two distribution and I suppose that
a set of distribution that are defined
implicitly by a generator and I supposed
a mixture convex membrane see mixture
convex to mean convex respect to the set
of mixed chuckles so that's what it
means basically for every mixture there
is theta T such that pushing mute to G
TTT give me my distribution and the
problem is that if p0 and p1 f de Jonge
support with nonzero margin then either
t2 theta T is discontinuous or theta to
GT ties this continues in both cases is
going to be very hard to learn because
running discontinuous function is not
fun written for optimization and the
proof is simple let's take two
distribution p0 p1 with this John she
falls apart by some margin new just the
here and for all epsilon positive is
however small G theta 0 of Z the output
of G theta 0 always belong to the
support of p0 because pushing forward
you through G theta 0 implements p0 and
for all epsilon G theta epsilon Z
belongs the web belongs to the support
of P 1 with probability epsilon that if
you have a mixture however small some of
the Zed's
must be diverted from p0 to the support
of p0 to the support of p1 that means
that therefore there is a Zed so that
the distance between G theta 0 of Z and
D theta epsilon of Z is greater than mu
and that regardless of how powerful is
epsilon so this essentially means that
if you have a mixture curve in
probability space and you want to take a
curve between these two distribution you
have continuity as to break someone
cannot be continuous
so but this means that the mixture
curves do not match the geometry of
implicit models not at all we need all
the kind of curves and while you go to
displacement curves so I go back with
visage time a transportation plan from
p0 to p1 is a John distribution was
marginal at p0 and p1 and with this
optimal one the expectation of D XY to
the P expectation respect to the John
distribution is minimal so the exponent
P is the one of the visage and P
distance and the same drawing here now
indirectly the N case because if the
underlying space is not clear the end
you have to follow geodesics is more
complicated but let's take the simple
case displacement curve is I'm going to
define PT as pushing forward mixture
through the optimal transport plan that
means that I take my optimal transport
plan and I take my grains of or et
starting from the distribution P if I
follow the full transport plan I'm going
to queue but in the transport I'm just
going to drop them at a fraction T of
the way and see what distribution I get
now let's suppose that p 0 is a
chiquitos Europe a schmooze the push
forward of mu through G theta 0 and P 1
the push rod of new to be theta 1 well
if I push forward both I have a John
distribution that's a transportation
plan and if I push forward a combination
of the two I have displacement curves
for this transportation plan so
basically if the family of GTT function
are strong enough approximation property
this can be close to the optimal plan so
actually needed because I can take the T
theta zero theta one I want and
this new optimal displacement can be
close to G theta T asking you so
basically again with a bunch of caveats
but uh if I can be complicated and don't
really want to over clean here I'm just
going to say that when the GTA family is
rich enough and approximates well it's
natural that displacement curves are
inside the family so basically the
displacement convexity is a natural
notional convexity for family of
distributions defined by an implicit
model and such families are typically
not mixture convex because of the
argument if they are you have not
discontinuities that are going to make
them useless and you can contrast this
with families defined by parametric
density functions when your apartment
with density function if the permit
frequency function is high approximation
property chance that is going to be able
to approximate a superposition or
mixture and neglected here for mixture
curves are quite natural when you
estimate densities but when you have an
implicit models the natural curves
already are displacement and the
question is which cost function are
displaced non-convex them because that's
another piece of crap so remember I
implicit modeling and I'm going to give
a couple facts first one is how
different of a such time and MMD I'll
leave aside the Strom topology because
they're also of discontinuity problems
was the topic of the West Indian paper
and I take the visage Tynan energy
distance and when you spend them in dual
form they're very close the only thing a
difference is the supremum
on which each one function function that
one which is bounded on Vassar Stein and
the HHS go for MMD and because I'm an
ignorant I thought oh that's really very
close because yeah I discovered that
it's a pretty big difference is it was
clearly clear but this one is really
bigger but it's not because you can
approximate a lot of things with HHS
that the a cage is Bohr is close to
which this one ball anyway you can then
discuss the geodesics when the space of
distribution is equipped with the energy
distance oh I'm in the distance you can
show that the shortest path with two
distributions is just the mixture curve
except we think look at the shortest
path because when you minimize the
distance the shortest path is something
quite important in terms of convexity
when the space of distribution is equal
to vi NP the only shortest paths are
displacement curves and what's just an
one you have both of them and all kinds
of high hog with the curves that are a
little bit displacement indeed mixture
in different parts of the space all
different elevenses the certain one has
a lot of geophysics statistical
properties if I look at the expected
distance between a distribution Q and is
empirical approximation on endpoints
well for energy distance it's in 1 over
N for versus tan is 1 over N to the 1
over D dimension so it's a catastrophe
and this is which Sanjeev Arora is a
nice example you can use fear where this
is completely reached and that seems
completely hopeless but what's happening
when you run it in practice
EDM MD works well in low dimension this
is what was in the blue chakra paper the
other paper is different in highly
mentions get stuck very quickly whereas
the vast earth time training seems to
work quite well I wouldn't say it's very
easy or smooth of all it works as well
as normal neural network but this sort
of works and so to make an example
it is the typical some bedrooms another
used in all these early image generation
problems these are the examples when you
train with MMD a certain neural network
you get that these are the generations
when you train it with a certain
distance you get this same network so
why is it that the thing that has the
most horrible statistical properties you
can think of works so much better and I
know that this picture looking at it's
the kind of beauty contest it doesn't
say that much but still you know it's
it's a consistent effect that you can
see a lot of data sets
there is something now
so how things can go wrong
okay this is an example super simple
with uniformly it's completely made up
but it's made up to show that it's
possible to have a situation where the
energy distance has local minima and the
second one doesn't
it's a made-up example is designed to do
that but Alice is a proof of concept
that you can get local minimum with
energy distance that you don't get with
massage time now I spoke about the
convexity of the families Alice to pick
about the convexity of the distance
function so what I'm going to minimize
this dqp theta so the cost function p 2
d QP is it mixture convex is
displacement context so mixture convex
is easy because you have straight lines
so it works that's easy this specimen
convex is more complicated because I
have first to convince you that this is
not generally true in a metric space so
just take the attacker l to equipped
with the l1 distance so the Manhattan
just like distance except without the
discretization of the street the
geodesics are just growing vertically
then horizontally in the simplest way so
this cross here is l1 is convex when you
equip two with the l1 distance in terms
of the soil it's convex we respect to
the set of geodesics induced by the l1
metric inner tube but the intersection
of two convex set is not necessary
convex not even connected in addition if
you take the distance to zero you see
that these two curves here are geodesics
but the blue one is clearly convex if
you take the distance close to zero and
the red one is not so basically it's not
a given
and okay mixture works the vast ocean
distant is not displacement convex or
use a counter example the Q which is
uniform on the circle
is uniform on the stick that rotates in
the center the stick has length 2 L if
you display plot the search time of Q
between PL and theta doesn't depend on
theta because his rotationally symmetric
depends only on L it decreases so
basically when the stick is bigger the
Vashon distance is smaller this is quite
intuitive actually now rotate the stick
a little bit and do a displacement
interpolation between p1 and p0 is
taking pity here but this PT is not
following a curve is following a
straight line so this are called
this dot dot line here straight that
means that the great segment is a bit
shorter than p0 and p1 and because this
is a bit shorter the vastest and
distance is bigger they still hope and
basically what you get the hope is that
you can write the theorem that I don't
like too much because the bound is too
gross but that shows that even though
there is a violation of the convexity
you can bound it by your term in T 1
minus T times something now that
something doesn't decrease when I
increase G theta
you see why I don't like it it's a fixed
quantity that depends on the function
and so when you the proof is some
glueing thing that's pretty much
eliminate re is just a bit cumbersome
but not even actually it's not very
difficult and then you can apply the
almost convex optimization theorem and
conclude that there is a guarantee that
optimizing an implicit model with vast
search time as only local minima whose
value is near that of the global minimum
but the knee is not nearly as good as
the one I had with neural networks
because I cannot reduce it by increasing
the approximation function even if I
could approximate exactly my function
was it was
convex respect to visage time distance
my family of functions converge to
respect vs. and this is exactly and we
still have this extra time so well I was
absurd with this but anyway I think it's
interesting to see because it's an
example where something that's essential
for machine learning which is the
geometry of variety distribution can
be equipped with curves that are very
different from mixtures and sometimes
you have to in the case of implicit
models and you can still get some kind
of convexity results and optimization
results in that way and when we watch
the paper so Thalia was not psyched
about this result and the theorem too
simple to me but my observation was that
this kind of results really they're not
that simple they're much more difficult
to get in general in the literature and
with time my starting to change my mind
and thinking that me may be actually
this trivial theorem is not that bad
because it makes a lot of difficult
results quite simple so my conclusion is
that convexity with active mixture
curves make clear that optimizing a
regression model with strong
approximation opportunities recentl will
yield zani global minimum this property
is independent of the exact parameter
ization it says nothing about the
implicit biases and used by the
parameterization and how best to exploit
them in implicit generative models
convexity respect to displacement curves
seems more natural than capacity with
rechtin mixture curves and is that a
potential here like think about images
no in images mixture of images
piece-of-crap
do know that images natural geometry is
a displacement geometry and so there
might be a potential to use weird curves
and prove interesting things for some
kind of networks in particular all the
networks that work so well in images but
I haven't done that and I don't know how
to do it so that's it
[Applause]
yeah I did not understand about - when
you started to talk about generalization
I mean the but one was all about the
training no I didn't talk about
generalization at all no thing you know
is what I'm saying at some point up
there it's like oh it's going so it's so
talk to justice this is I see I see uh
so the property that ensures that the
decent are going we can go to a near
global minimum is reduced to some kind
of convexity property it doesn't depend
on the parametrization yet the
parametrization is what the decent
algorithm follows because we work in the
binary space and therefore it creates
increasing bias
they're going to decide which solution
you're going to find and if you do early
stopping they're going to decide where
you stop now picture for instance a
solution space so it's a level set at
zero level so we connected to that's
very bizarre in theta space the result
says that up to that level set I'm
connected so I can go to one of them but
doesn't say that I'm going to go to a
good one on the other hand by changing
the way the family of functions
parameterize even if it's the same
familiar function I'm changing this
geometry quite a lot and I could very
well reach the solution that's superior
in tempo generalization I could and if I
do this is something that's very problem
dependent because it is actually depends
on how the parameter ization is set up
proof of that in the if you take the
paper that the lazy learning paper of
constants and student and I should
remember his name I'm sorry she's up
okay
besides all I don't know something like
this okay
anyway if you take this paper today they
show empirically that the solution you
get by following the the tangent channel
tends to underperform on both tasks and
then there is a kind of argument of but
at the end of the paper the beginning of
the paper is sure that this kind of
laser learning can appear in lot of
others when you change
scaling in particular ways so so it's a
it's not a rare property and it doesn't
give much in terms of generalization
guarantees not clear this solution is a
very good one that's quite consistent
with things we know in practice now that
the camel meat of the world they give
solutions but in practice this don't
seem to general as well as a CNN on
image stuff for good reasons because the
parameter ization of the CNN is very
well-suited to image stuff but one does
not explain what you're saying right
part one part one explains that the
property of going to a near global
minimum is only geometrical things
that's not that's optimization dependent
since parametrization is an orthogonal
concern and as an impact on the implicit
bias it's going to matter this is one
thing is all I'm saying
establish publicity with respect to a
the displacement curves or extra curves
and I do something to the descent
algorithm now that I know that the
problem is convinced under this class of
curves can i one I've no ID and two even
if you do it it doesn't mean is going to
take you to the right solution somehow I
think that the fact that you take a
model that's at the same time very
powerful in terms of proximation
property and at the and at the same time
is a very convoluted or worked on in
terms of pamification
is something that's useful it's nice to
decoupled all those no you can say well
with models that are this powerful I'm
going to find a solution and now I can
work on the dramatization to make it
suitable for my problem and doing so I'm
changing the dynamics of the learning
algorithm maybe towards more interesting
stuff so great very much with the
philosophy it is
but you know that the idea that if the
level in level sets are connected then
the same target would find the global
minimum is intuitively appealing
tweetable appealing but it's not sparked
from audience right I mean you need
because it can be it we have the descent
algorithms in continuous time and then I
have the same pattern if she only
contains bounded speed curves or local
minima fr global social anagen that
finds a global minimum look on my
symmetry global and for the film powder
almost one I didn't do that but this is
some kind of proof right but they could
be that the side couldn't it be that the
scientist so you know perhaps this is
ruled out by the pounding speed curves
what you need ascetic suppose for
instance that the number of parameters
that you're using is exponential of
course you will not be able to you know
you some it algorithm for long as what I
mean I didn't speak about point if given
algorithm that does this sent in a
reasonable way meaning that you can say
is going to find a local minimum then is
going to find a new global one this is
all I mean really it's not the level set
is a kind of Wiggly argument but focus
is geometry basic sub level offense but
you still don't converge to that's why I
bounded speed to get the what's
happening with the bounded speed yes
that's one actually basically if I take
a local minimum so base be Iran might
want X of a kind of space in which is
I'm going up on staying flat and I have
a bounded below I need to draw a line
between the center of this flat zone and
below and because the zone is flattest
to go below at some point and that
contradicts the endpoint convexity I can
grow it if you want maybe
you have X and a 1x my function is flat
I have Y that I assume below so if I
take a curve between x and y and this
curve has banded speed basically I can
find the key somewhere that's below and
so basically the the value of the
function in gamma t as to be higher than
this linear decent line so basically
that shows you think that the bounded
speed is very important there and in the
other case actually we lost data that is
even simpler well it's a CLE the same
thing you know you have the set point
that lambda below you have the level M
you have X you have a flood zone here
and well you want to go to Z and if you
said is sufficiently low you're going to
have your uark aquatic arctor entirely
below
so basically but for this we need
bounded speed because you need to know
that when you move T by a little bit you
don't make a huge displacement in the in
the function space or the bounds p
detected why did it well that's the the
flood zone the bounded speed is actually
is here I think so but if I try to find
it now I'm going to find it wrong
yes yeah so personally hello every
self-esteem or so approximator how do
you guarantee that you'll find is
continuous every pointer is an
approximate or but maybe these artists
discrete things right yeah I realized
that when I said it because I know
exactly how to show that you can find a
bunch of points that function without
the continuity that's quite easy you
know you bound outside you and that one
I don't know yet I'm sorry I just
realized when I said that there is a
continuity issue that one has to
you might have to be able to approximate
the function and also derivatives
[Applause]